to colombia now which is seeing a wave
of violence against the police as a new
president prepares to take office
at least 25 officers have been killed so
far this year dozens more have been
injured in attacks using firearms and
explosives colombians have mourned the
dead individuals nationwide officials
say the powerful gulf clan drug cartel
is behind most of the murders and may
even be offering rewards for targeting
security forces
well let's go to dw's johann ramirez in
bogota for more johann what's behind
these attacks
the government
says that behind these attacks is the
clande gold for the golf clan this is
the the major criminal organization of
the country one of the biggest drug
gangs in latin america these attacks are
supposed to be a retaliation against the
authorities for the extradition of the
leadership gang otto niel ortoniel was
captured by the end of last year and
after many hearings and a long process
he was extra direct extradited to the
united states a couple of months ago
just to give you an idea nicole of the
importance of autoniel after pablo
escobar the great drug lord in colombia
otonil is the most prominent figure in
drug trafficking in this country so his
extradition is a major blow for this
criminal organization and the reason why
they have declared this kind of war
against the police
now that you mentioned pablo escobar
colombia is of course a country scarred
by decades of brutal cartel violence at
the hands of his medellin cartel how
concerned are people about violence
flaring up once again
it's hard to imagine nicole but
here in colombia people
are just get
i mean are just used to to to live with
violence let's remember that the country
went through a civil war that lasted
more than 50 years so violence had
become
a kind of daily a part of a daily life
in the country but colombia reached the
peak of violence back in the 80s and 90s
the the golden era of drug trafficking
the golden era of pablo escobar so i
think that there is the general
perception that when it comes to
violence the words the worst is already
behind so this wave of violence that hit
the country from time to time
are just seen by colombians as a part of
daily life in the country
still this is a problem that needs to be
tackled in 10 days colombia's new
government will be sworn in how is the
new administration going to deal with
the problem
the good news for the next government is
that this clande gold for the biggest
criminal organization of the country
with other 30 criminal gangs released a
letter last week proposing a peace
accord to the to the next administration
of gustavo petro they are proposing to
stop every criminal activity to hand
over their weapons in exchange of pardon
and warranties of non-prosecution so
this could open the door for a
negotiation for a peace accord between
the state and these criminal
organizations but we cannot take it for
granted let's remember that something
similar already happened in the past
back in 2017 with the then president
juan manuel santos and today um nobel
peace prize winner the clandell golf
also proposed a peace accord to that
government and after some negotiations
it failed so now the next weeks and the
next months are going to be key to see
if this new proposal finally works
bringing peace to the country all right
interesting stuff john ramirez reporting
from bogota thank you so much
you